people always look at the industrial
sector and think it's a thing of the
past the truth cannot be farther away
from this I think most people say oh
industrial like that's so boring and
sleepy compared to uh Bitcoin is it
boring and sleepy I think one sentence
summarizes it all we're all in the
basement while the party's in the
penthouse the good thing the Silver
Lining coming out of covered people said
even in a virtual world I need physical
Goods all right guys bang bang I've got
Nick here with me uh the entire American
industrial industry seems to have gone
through highs lows everything in between
I read the news and it makes it feel
like American Industrial Revolution is
over we will never see the industrial
industry come back it's all being
outsourced it's over you wrote a book
called the titanium economy which
basically argues the exact opposite uh
what are people missing in the
mainstream conversation around the
industrial industry
Anthony you started off with the right
message people always look at the
industrial sector and think it's a thing
of the past they look at it and very
sadly say wow this was a great sector it
was stolen it was lost it was given away
the truth cannot be farther away from
this we are in the first Enix why let's
just start with what the industrial
sector is if you look around anything
and everything you touch you see you do
on a daily day
starts because it was made by the
industrial sector innovated by the
industrial sector let's just start with
two examples you wake up in the morning
you grab your cup of coffee you walk out
doesn't matter which city you are in you
walk on the deck
the deck is made of composite materials
which are
amazing innovation in material
processing for example a company called
tracks which we talk about in our book
does it
you wouldn't think about it you would
think it's common Lumber but actually
the deck is made by recycled plastic
bottles protecting the environment and
protecting you when you're standing on
it you run to the airport you have to go
somewhere and like always you're going
to be late and you're going to go to
Starbucks or grab a cup of coffee and a
muffin you want the muffin heated up the
muffin is heated up in an oven made by a
company called well built which heats up
the muffin in 15 seconds nicely warm
regularly heated because of innovation
and how you heat up your food and last
you're boarding your plane let's hope
you're in Phoenix or Minneapolis too hot
too cold what keeps the plane hot or
cold is because of what's called Ground
support equipment made by companies like
dabico which keeps the plane hot or cold
when it's on the ground without having
to turn on the engine and burning
valuable jet fuel again an amazing
Innovation so I can continue on Anthony
but and that is like the first 10
minutes of your day on a typical day
roll this out everything is done by the
industrial sector and all of those are
driving Innovation almost on a daily
basis without which we would be stuck
so I'm very excited to talk to you
because I feel like people who are
entrepreneurs and investors will find
you specifically uh and your partners uh
interesting in terms of the model that
you take so the industrial sector is uh
this huge thing that touches everything
people think it's a thing of the past
you all are very excited uh you uh and
two other folks who wrote uh the book
ended up uh originally working at
McKinsey you left high paying jobs to go
and do this and what you all are doing
is a combination of being an
entrepreneur and an operator with also
being an investor and so help me
understand like why are you leaving your
job like what what are you guys going to
do and why not just be investors or why
not just be operators why take kind of
this hybrid model
Anthony two parts to that question one
is if you look at the industrial sector
and we talk about it in the book there's
not one or two there were 35 companies
we profiled several of them have done
better than S P 500 in stock exchange in
stock performance so put it very bluntly
as an investor would you want to invest
in the next Facebook Amazon absolutely
but you're taking a gamble because you
don't know what's the next Facebook or
the next Amazon versus an industrial
sector pretty much the odds of picking
the winner is very hard every company
does well they create a lot of
shareholder value and you can do it but
what is more interesting is when you
take the same companies
and you infuse the capabilities to
transform them what we call the segment
of one leaders are having a great
product which solves a customer problem
having the customer intimacy having the
ability to deliver product within the
time it needs within the right quality
you have amazing performance a company
called haiko which is based right here
which is probably five blocks from this
office has outperformed pretty much
every Fang stock over the last 30 years
in stock exchange performance and that
is because Larry Mendelson who's the CEO
and the chairman is a very active
engaged investor he's not just invested
the money but he has actually invested
and transformed the company and our
model is the same thing let's be an
Engaged investor operator
three keywords engaged to a very engaged
in the company with the management to
make sure we're getting the right
products to the right customers at the
right time
we are investors we put our money
because we obviously want a good return
on our capital and we are operators we
actually operate the company we put in
the right management team we put in our
talent and all of that combined creates
a huge Alpha and when there's an
opportunity like that our whole premise
is we can talk about it in a book in
McKinsey which we did but let's eat our
own cooking and let's actually go do
this on our own and that's what we're
doing at the phone B group so there's a
specific example that you've told me uh
where a company was struggling it's
publicly traded company
um I believe it was about 100 million
dollar market cap or so uh it then
became worth tens of billions of dollars
uh in a fairly short period of time
let's use that company specifically what
is the company what did they do and
let's kind of walk through the model as
to what you all did to help folks
understand how this model can actually
have a very profound impact on
businesses
so let's pick any company for that
matter
usually these companies have Revenue
they have good margins or decent margins
but they struggle because they really
don't know what good looks like the
question is in this particular company
the one you talked about it was a 400
million dollar company publicly traded
so we'll sort of keep the name off but
people can make a wild guess and was
struggling and losing money
when we were able to engage with that
company what we did is we said look
let's start with the basics let's pay
cash cash pays the bill it's not EPS
it's not ebitda it's cash
two we said we really need to have the
best product out there so this is not
about cutting costs and firing people we
need to have the right cost structure
but let's actually have a product which
the customer wants let's try the
Innovation engine
and third let's get the right people in
the right seats whether it's the CEO
whether it's a CFO whether it is a
header supply chain and let's give them
the right incentives
and what we found very interesting is
everybody wakes up in the morning and
says I want to do a good job I don't
think anybody wakes up since I want to
do a crappy job
but a lot of people don't know what good
looks like and so the step one was what
we call creating the transparency of
where you are versus where you should be
so it was very clear in this particular
company they were at 18 gross margin and
they thought being a 20 gross margin was
good and we said no 40 is a good number
which was beyond their Thinking Beyond
their thought process we said look you
have a great product you have a great
brand you should be a 40. similarly we
said once we got that we got that
communication account across the entire
Workforce it's not just what was in the
board or the c-suite we got the whole
company at that time to realize we are
really good
we just have to be as good as we claim
to be let's go deliver not only in
developing products not only in delivery
not only in customer service let's do
that
and then the last one was in a lot of
areas there was big gaps and we said
let's take the actions for example in
pricing
pricing was a great example they thought
they were doing a great job they added a
lot of value to their customers but was
not extracting it in pricing and their
argument as well our customers are not
good except the high price we said well
if you create value they are so we were
able to go optimize pricing same thing
with cost optimization their products
had a 25 year warranty when in reality
the industry had only a 15-year warranty
and we said great have a 25 year
warranty but if the customer's demand
for it they're going to pay for it let's
right size the products
the list goes on it was not one thing it
was thousand small things but when you
added up it had a huge impact on the
performance and everybody wants to be a
part of a winning team once the flywheel
started going people said wow this is
not good enough they went from losing 24
cents a share to break even to 10 cents
and they said why should we be 10 cents
a share we should be 18 cents a share
once they were 18 cents a share they
were like we should be 35 cents a share
and the sky became the limit
fast forward the movie later this is a
company which has gone from less than
100 million dollar market cap to north
of 30 billion over a period of five
years
and and what is the importance of the
team because I think that um there's a
saying when good team meets bad market
market wins when bad team meets good
market market wins uh you've mentioned
the team a couple times what is the
importance of having the right people in
the right seats as you described
it begins and ends with the team money
is a commodity if I have a dollar and
you have a dollar it's the same thing
it's what's the team which does with it
at Funway we say we only bet on the
teams every time we look at a company to
invest in if we have a good team
either already in place or a team we
know we will lean forward how do you
evaluate them so so a good team is this
uh their past performance conversations
with them like like walk me through the
process of evaluating the team so the
way I would put it and this is something
we use even in Fern Bay we use a very
simple model called Oro GID oh no g-i-d
stands for outcomes and ownership and
get it done okay it comes down to very
simple things do you really have an
outcomes orientation put it differently
you have to hit a certain revenue and
margin Target that's the outcome
a lot of management will say oh I tried
really hard I talked to three guys you
know the Ukraine crisis happened and the
cryptocurrency collapsed what do you
want me to do well that's amazing input
it's not the outcomes you're not an
owner in that you're having a more an
employee and an input mindset so that
makes the biggest distinction Anthony
which is is it or window and the second
one is GID is get it done it really
doesn't matter I mean obviously do it
right do it legally but get it done
think about it how many times when
somebody calls you and says well I
really tried my level best I was
supposed to do this this is
you really don't have a lot of patience
at the end you say did you get it done
the answer is no then well you really
wasted my time did you get it done and
then you want to bask in the glory
fantastic I'll listen to you for us it
really comes down to that very simple
thing which is do you have orendo and
GID which really then comes up to is
what's your clocks what we call what's
your clock speed how quickly do you get
it done because even let's say you're
not good at what you do if you move fast
you get multiple chances to back
if you fail you fail fast and you fail
free and you learn from that and if you
look at this and when we were at
McKinsey we looked at management teams
across a lot of companies
and when we are now at Funway we use
this as our Benchmark which is if the
management team has that mindset of
orino GID they always win they always
find a way even when they hit a road
bomb they find a detour versus if they
think hey I did all I can what do you
want me to do
I mean then you have an employee in hand
you have to manage them you have to
check the box you give them a checklist
they say I checked the list and you're
well that doesn't get me to what I want
I mean if you're an investor you want to
make money if you're a customer you want
the product delivered to you if you're a
supplier you want to be paid I mean I
always tell my employers if I come to
you and say well John I'm not going to
pay you this year's salary and they're
like what do you mean well I really
tried hard I talked to Anthony 17 times
but he didn't fund my company you know
like I don't care I need my salary
would you give me credit for trying the
answer is no and that model works
everywhere and people need to get that
head around that is its own GID so how
do you evaluate potential CEOs to bring
in uh to these companies because it's
interesting right you you underwrite a
team and some of the teams you say hey
we're gonna come in we're gonna help
optimize whatever we're going to back
you and We're Off to the Races we
already have a team other times you
actually may bring in a new CEO or new
management team what is that process
like to find the right person because
it's probably the most important
decision that you're going to make once
you decide to do a deal absolutely so
far we are lucky in every deal we have
done we have brought the CEO the CFO who
we have known for the last 20 years so
you look at the company availa
infrastructure which we just closed
which we spun out from Azz the CEO the
CFO the head of HR we have known for
north of 10 years the CEO is an amazing
CEO a guy by the name of Bill Johnson he
used to be the CEO of uh Dover after
that a chart and well built so we knew
him almost three companies and I
personally know him very well and he's a
guy
I have 100 confidence not even 99
confidence he knows how to deliver so
when I have him at the seat
I don't even need to think twice
on the flip side you ask this great
question we were looking at a company we
didn't have the right management team we
found a person who we thought we liked
but as we dug in and went more into
diligence what we found is we really
didn't know whether they had that values
to drive that and
we could have taken that risk but we
said no so to answer your question so
far we have been lucky we just have a
track record of having known them for 10
20 years and in some cases we we really
go more to see whether they have the
Orlando GID but My worry is the next
five years that's going to be our
biggest gaining Factor we have to find
the right guys guys and gals and we have
to put them in and that is our biggest
differentiating Factor how do you decide
where the big opportunities are in
industrial so okay we understand how to
pick the teams now when you pick the
right Market sector uh do you kind of
have like prepared mind approach where
like you guys have done a bunch of work
and you go looking for a company you're
kind of on the hunt do you wait for
people to pitch you and you go learn
about a sector like how does that
process work
three comments industrial is a very
broad term if you look about it it's a
very heterogeneous sector one side is
you have the Amazon rainforest and one
side you have the Antarctica scope so
what we have done is we have taken the
industrial sector and broken it up into
90 micro verticals
some of them you know really well some
of them we don't know at all so rule
number one we start with the sectors we
know
uh if you don't know that itself is
erect not a red flag at least in yellow
flag so we say is that something be
worthwhile to go in where we have not
done our homework so first flag is is it
a sector we know
second is
what we call the structural factors most
of us not all of us most of us are first
generation immigrants and so we say rule
number one through rule number 99 is
capital preservation we don't want to I
mean we would love to get a 10x return
20x written pick a number but we want to
make sure there's a high probability
we'll get our Capital back and so we
when we look at the sector when we look
at the company we say
how comfortable we are that we're going
to get our Capital back the investment
we made
some of them is we buy companies with
very high networking Capital very high
asset base so we feel good
but related to that we also say we are
more than comfortable betting on
ourselves
we are not bearing we are not
comfortable betting on things we don't
control EG we don't go into a sector
where there's a big government subsidy
because it might stay it might lead we
don't know about that
we don't go into sectors where there's a
high threat of substitution because of
global warming climate change and we're
like it could happen could not happen
that's not a bet we can take so we apply
critical parameters to say we are more
than happy to double down on risk we
will take we will not take risk we don't
control
and the third thing is as they say the
proof is the numbers we look at that and
say okay what are the variables we
control as we talked about before
revenues cost margin and we say do we
feel comfortable over the period of time
we can double our eBay dollars and if
the answer is yes absolutely and then we
would be more than happy to get a
multiple expansion we'll be more than
happy to drive more inorganic growth but
Capital preservation combined prior
doubling or ebitda which you can do the
math leads to a very healthy mom irr we
would do it uh if not we are more than
happy to walk away and last thing
related to question is we don't
typically participate in auctions every
deal we do is a proprietary deal or a
lot of deals we do is proprietary deals
and the reason is one we know the
industrial sector so people know us they
call us and it's always fun when you do
it with your friends uh so we do it with
people we know we like we trust it
allows us to have a high level of trust
so we are not
gaming the system we go in with a
win-win partnership model I mean you
look at every deal we've done I can tell
you with a high level of confidence the
counterparty will say hey this was a
good deal for me as well so that allows
us to really play the game we are good
at rather than go play a game we have
never played before
as you are evaluating things like
margins and different aspects of pricing
you mentioned earlier warranty stuff
like that is there
accrued knowledge over time and so you
know going into a business okay we know
that we can increase prices we can do
this and there's like an actual Playbook
or is each company so unique in that you
have to start kind of from the basics
ground up and build a plan as to what
you're going to do with that business
right because because you could see both
where sometimes it's Unique sometimes
it's just like hey we got our operating
manual let's go in we know what to do uh
and we do it how do you all approach it
this episode is brought to you by ate
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
and eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep I would say it's probably
80 20 of fuel mix what I mean by that is
in a lot of these sectors we have served
companies before we know these companies
um I've been in the sector for more than
30 years so there's a big patent
recognition uh you can go into a company
and say wow this is a company we should
be a 20 ebitda it's at eight
maybe I'm wrong but at least I can get
it to 15. so there's a huge pattern
recognition related to that even if I
don't know personally there are five
people I know very well I can call up
and say Anthony I'm looking at this
company I think it should be a 15 but uh
do you think I'm smoking pot no I've
I've been a CEO I have a supply chain
guy so I can do that so that allows us
to have the first 80 Comfort level
and then a few times you're gone and
this is not a sector we know then we do
first order problem solving we say well
I don't know
let's really think if this company is at
five percent ebitda can we get it to a
15 ebitda and we go and literally
uncover every Rock uh we as I say we are
confident but we are not cocky
um and I tell this to my team every time
we will make a mistake I just don't know
when and I hope it's not on this deal
but remember we are going to make a
mistake and so that allows us to go and
say is this something we can really get
that number
and a couple of times we have walked
away because we couldn't get that
Comfort level
uh I think most people say oh industrial
like that's so boring and sleepy
compared to uh Bitcoin or uh high growth
Tech or you know name your uh AI ml uh
you know favorite startup whatever
and then you think of like Russia
invades Ukraine and all of a sudden
everyone becomes a Commodities expert
everyone becomes an industrial expert
right
um we pull out of Afghanistan and people
I literally see them on Twitter talking
about like does China or the Taliban
control that mine right and like you
start to realize like hey wait a second
like there are real world consequences
and there's a lot of geopolitical
natures to it and everything is it
boring and sleepy and we're all just uh
uh maybe or are we all not paying
attention and like maybe this is way
crazier uh and if we started to pay
attention to it we would think it's just
as cool as some of this other stuff I
think one sentence summarizes it all uh
one of my friends said it and I I stole
it from him we're all in the basement
while the party's in the penthouse
um we would love to get from the
basement to the first floor
would we ever get to the penthouse I
hope so uh but the culture of the sector
um drives that behavior if you look at
these SEC these companies they're not in
Silicon Valley they're not in Miami
they're not in New York they're in
Fulton Missouri they're in Pittsburgh
Kansas
um they're in Chattanooga Tennessee and
what you find are amazing men and women
doing the work but they're not the folks
who are going to go and browbeat and say
this is amazing what we do is great so
this is a sector which typically does
not do a great job in marketing itself
they just do their job and get about it
and so for a long time exactly as you
said what was more sexy was the AI
autonomous driving
um
Bitcoin I mean you name it NFD well I
think covert and then the geopolitical
uh tensions whether that was U.S China
or now Ukraine Russia people said oh
wait a minute if for example Russia
turns off gas Ukraine people are going
to freeze and if Russia turns off gas
more than 40 percent I think was a
number quoted of manufacturing is going
to shut down and people said wow I can't
be cold well I need to control my
destiny I mean back to my point I need
to build a basement before I build the
penthouse I think that awareness is
coming but your original question will
we be sexy probably not do we need to be
sexy I don't know I would say I mean
I've been in sector for more than 30
years I'm more than happy being in the
basement
um we have a it's a very Vibrant
Community
we create a lot of value to the
communities we play in uh in a lot of
the companies we have served we have
looked at there's not one or two
multiple people will stay in the company
for 20 30 years 40 years and have
retired as a millionaire with their 401k
and that's an amazing satisfaction when
you can say look this company pick a
number 20 of the people are going to
retire as a millionaire I mean is this
the true American dream and I think as a
sector we enable that and
I'm hoping we'll get the recognition I
mean that's one of the reasons why we
wrote the book but even if we don't I
think it's totally fine because it's
such a vibrant part of who we are and
defines who we are as a country as a
sector as a society
and I think that will continue
Russia Ukraine has had a big impact on
uh on the overall industry or not really
uh globally yes U.S no interesting um
the reason is
if you think about it gas natural gas is
the best and this has nothing to do with
global warming it's a fact uh today if
you want to heat up anything space
heating gas is your best uh driver not
electric uh not obviously hopefully not
wood gas and if you live in cold
countries which is a lot of Northern
Europe you need gas uh fact of life
unless you are willing to go back to
prehistoric times or Ice Age and so if I
stop that the fundamental premise is
what do you do
so you need it for
the consumer if you're in Poland you're
in Germany you're in France uh you're in
Estonia I just pick any countries there
you need gas so if I turn that off it
I don't want to say cushions your
survival but it really does question
your survival or at least a comfortable
living
second pretty much any hardcore
manufacturing making steel
which you and I touch everywhere I mean
whether it is a EV car or
you use a PC for Bitcoin mining it's you
need steel for that needs heat and heat
comes from gas uh the gas being the
primary medium so I think that is
fundamentally question people saying
what you took for granted think of it
this way Anthony if I say all of a
sudden you're not going to get half the
water you consume every day
you're like I've never thought about
that because wherever I go I'm gonna get
a bottle of water and I've never thought
what is a it's going to be a scarce
commodity it's maybe not to that extreme
but it's one of that and the second is I
think it's tied to the geopolitical
angle which is for a long time people
believed and I I believe too in
globalization which is I'm going to do
what I'm going to be good at you do what
you're good at and now people said well
probably that's not going to work as
seamlessly as I thought it to be and so
I need to control my own destiny and you
started to see that in the US when
covert hit this has nothing to do with
geopolitical borders crossed borders
closed when bot is closed you couldn't
get the stuff you needed you needed to
have it within your own four walls and
so a lot of that is now creating that
awareness saying the industrial sector
is a core part of enabling everything
you do and you better not Outsource that
and I as you start to look at the
industrial sector itself in the U.S
right so you have all this kind of
geopolitical stuff that's playing out
but inside the United States it hasn't
really affected that much uh there's
some very big players uh one that comes
to mind is like the coke Industries
right uh and what's always fascinating
is I'm not an expert on this I don't
know how much you know about them
specifically but uh it appears that in
the industrial sector you build these
huge conglomerates and what I've never
really understood is how much of that is
a product of there being uh various
benefits to combining a bunch of
industrial companies together so you get
efficiencies at scale and and can share
some back office stuff or whatever
versus no they've got a lot of money and
like there's a lot of opportunity and so
uh people just end up being capitalist
uh and they happen to be in Industrials
and like the conglomerate model isn't
necessarily as effective how do you
think through maybe like the business
structure and why have we seen so many
large mostly private or many private
companies that have kind of this
conglomerate thing with their hands in a
lot of different aspects of the industry
if you look at the industrial sector in
general they're extremely fragmented so
there are roughly 4 800 companies just
in the us alone on the industrial sector
half of them are privately held and 80
of them are mid cap so which is a very
good in a sense Live and Let Live dear
question I don't know the Koch brothers
that well so it'll be hard for me to
comment but I would say that is a a
point which defines the industrial
sector which is if you do well you're
going to generate a lot of cash and if
you generate a lot of cash you can buy
more companies so there is nothing which
prevents you from doing it
um you look at Coke they have their
hands in a lot of stuff just because
they have their hands and a lot of stuff
but you look on the flip side and you
look at for example I picked up well
build as a great example it was a
billion and a half dollar company making
amazing ovens in an 80 billion dollar
sector so you can whatever the math is
78 million or seven whatever 78.5
billion is controlled by a bunch of
other companies which is not those guys
and that well build was one of the
leaders so I do think
the industrial sector has always been
more fragmented than typically like tech
for example if you have to do a search
you're going to go to Google and if
you're in a mood you might do Bing but
after that you don't have any other guy
I don't think that's the case in
Industrials I think you'll find this is
a sector of Live and Let Live
um there are a lot of companies they do
very well they very well at what they do
they're very well at this they don't do
well the stuff they don't do but I think
that allows that model of hey I'm going
to stick to my knitting and sort of not
be all over as I don't know say worked
well but has created a very vibrant
sector and
the cash generation is uh fascinating
because most people in the tech industry
are like cash profit like what are you
guys talking about we we grow we invest
we lose money we like venture capital on
fire and to their credit like there are
some massive very valuable companies
that have been built there uh but the
industrial sector does not take the same
approach
what are the things that people do with
the cash are there companies that just
generate a bunch of cash and sit on it
or dividend it or is it pretty well
understood that there's like no
reinvestment strategy like talk to me a
little bit about this cash generation
you hit the nail of the head I live in
Silicon Valley and uh one of my friends
once told me I'm really unhappy today
this was three years of his company and
I said why he said I made a profit and I
was shocked I said why he said my VC
investors are really mad at me that I
was not growing fast enough and I
shouldn't be generating a cash I should
be investing for the future and then he
talked about why he's not able to hire
the right folks and so on and I looked
at him for like 30 seconds and I thought
that's fascinating a mindset because if
you're a company I would expect you to
make a profit and if you feel sad that
you made a profit I mean there's a lot
of ifs and butts and caveats but that's
a fascinating point a tech sector is
trained to believe for a long long time
you should not make profits the
industrial sector I think it is just a
Genesis of how they started most of them
are family start a family-owned a
Founder comes up with a brilliant idea
nobody believes him or her he says screw
it I'm gonna go prove you wrong
he mortgages his truck he mortgages his
you know wife's jewelry he does it and
he sort of says look if it's his money
there's no outer money and he grows the
business
um and that DNA sticks in that company
and it rolls out in the sector I can't
tell you Anthony how many companies I've
talked to private owned companies and
you ask them like
what's your relationship with Wall
Street or what's your relationship with
financial institutions and they'll give
me this blank look and the reason I'll
always be surprised after a long digging
they didn't need to have it they have no
intention of going public
and they're very well funded uh they
generate the cash they pay themselves
well you can call it dividend
recapitalization they continue to do it
I mean if you go to that model and I'm
not saying that model is right I'm not
saying that model is wrong but if you
believe in that model
I don't need the bankers I don't need
Wall Street and to your question then
what do people do with the cash 9 out of
10 times they invest in growing the
business that's how they grow the
business the old adage you make cash you
invest you pay your employees very well
uh you pay yourself very well and
sometimes when you need it you do a
dividend recapitalization but first most
part It's The Virtuous self-feeding
cycle is that the best way to grow a
business
Sean answer is no
um what you learn in business school is
OPM other people's money is a good way
to grow
um so maybe that is my business training
uh which I say hey look uh
do it but I think the broader question
Anthony is whether you take extra
capital or not it's your decision that's
just a risk conservative how
conservative you are and what risk you
take but I do believe and I tell this a
lot of these companies I know them very
well I've known them for Generations I
tell them you have to get external
Talent
whether you get extra capital or not
that's fine
talk to every Wall Street Banker I mean
you might never take your company IPO
that's okay that's a decision you want
to control it but talk to him or her
because you will learn a lot if you're
an insular you're not going to grow and
so I would sort of say
whether you take extra capital or not
your call completely up to you I mean my
dad is not a billionaire so I will take
other people's money and I'll use it to
grow and I'll make them a lot of money
I'll make myself a lot of money but if
you're well off and you say I don't need
the capital I don't want to give up
control I don't need you to tell me what
to do okay that's an operating model
question but I do believe you really
have to bring external talent in not
because you have to bring it just when
you bring diverse talent in you learn a
lot you question your thinking and at
Fern Bay one of the things we do is we
obviously invest but in a lot of
companies companies says I don't need
your Capital but can you help me
professionalize it I mean the code word
is look we have been two insular and one
of the things I really enjoy personally
doing it is when we go into the
companies they do a lot of things great
but then a lot of things they don't do
it's not a question that they don't do
great they just don't do and opening up
that aperture we find is fascinating on
how much value creation is there
and so I guess really
talking to the external people one they
have knowledge they have experienced is
it also that there's like weird family
Dynamics at play when people are
operating these family businesses
especially in the industrial industry
absolutely I think family is weird we
can just stop with that sentence I mean
we all have grown up with great families
big families
um families in general are weird you
would expect a family to be a Brady
Bunch family uh I don't know about you I
tell you from my family it has never
been that way you have the normal
infighting between siblings and cousins
and as Generations go on
um I mean it's hard for humans to
communicate with each other when there's
emotion involved yeah and when egos are
involved I remember in my third grade
you never came to my birthday party
you're like 50 years old can you let go
of the Third convert it but obviously it
matters
um and then when you furthermore put
money into it it gets worse and then
furthermore when you start putting
control into it it gets worse so I would
argue more companies struggle with it
than companies you got it right there
are some companies which have got it
right and they do a great job of
managing their intergenerational wealth
their intergeneration control uh
I know a few of them they've done great
uh as they say sleeve to sleep
generation to generation but a lot of
companies have done very well they've
done very well past the full Generation
Um when we looked at some data we found
is first generation does a great job
second generation remembers the first
generation so they continue doing a
great job they know what matters third
generation starts to drop off the fourth
generation is the do or die I mean very
if you're able to get past the fourth
generation you're in great shape so to
answer your question is it hard
absolutely it's hard everywhere
Industrials does it make harder probably
yes because their talent infusion or the
capability infusion from external is
lower on the lower side but I would
argue it's really no different than
any normal family
if you're watching these companies get
built they're getting passionate
Generation generation they're uh kind of
working here how does technology start
to play in because this is like a
fascinating thing so manufacturing which
which is uh somewhat similar to the
industrial space right now we're talking
about reshoring and Automation and
Robotics and again some of this like
sexy cool stuff right uh for what most
people would consider is like a kind of
a sleepy industry
is that happening also on the industrial
front are we talking about Robotics and
computer vision and Ai and can we do
certain things with this technology that
maybe previously wasn't possible and
we'll transform these businesses
it's a huge unlock some companies do it
some companies don't and that is why we
don't call them industrial companies we
call them industrial Tech because
there's a huge value in combining
industrial and technology and companies
which have done it have done it very
well Anthony and the short answer to
your question which you said absolutely
automation why should it not apply
Vision Vision AI absolutely it should so
um
is everybody doing it no but the guys
who have done it have done it have
captured huge value
so there's a couple parts in the book
that I want to uh talk about and one of
them I thought was fascinating uh is
haiko uh company uh looks for
well-managed entrepreneurial companies
playing in high margin Niche markets
that may be difficult to enter such as
companies that already carry needed
certifications now when I think of these
types of businesses moats Warren Buffett
right like all these things that I think
people kind of like ah it's the old
school immediately jump to mine how can
you tell if a company actually has a
real moat not like uh we think we kind
of sort of have a moat or our brand is
our moat right but like how do you
actually measure what is a mode and how
a company's can hold on to the mode as
they continue to face increased
competition
I think how you measure mode back to the
comment about Orlando it's all about
outcomes I measured it in margins if you
say you're an amazing company with an
amazing motor you make three percent
gross margin Anthony you don't have a
mode Let's be clear
um if you're a company with a 50 gross
margin
people go to their wallets people are
willing to give you a higher price
because you create higher value for them
so a mode for me shows up in the
performance of a company
operational performance and financial
performance how do you hold on to it
it's what Warren Buffett once said you
wake up every morning
saying you're going to treat the
customer as if you never knew him you
don't take it for granted companies
which hold on to their modes I tell them
don't take anything for granted because
easy come easy go even if you have an
amazing brand you have a great product
you have a great relationship you screw
up once you'll get an order delayed you
don't respond to the customer
they are going to try to that they might
not try but they might start thinking of
moving away from you so at least in our
portfolio companies we say very simple
don't give the customer an opportunity
to think about moving away from you
whether it is in product performance
operational performance how you treat
them how and look we all screw up but
when you screw up how well do you react
to it
simple I mean it seems very simple
um I'll give you a great example in
dabico this company we acquired it's an
amazing company uh with a great brand
great mode but we messed up we missed an
order for a customer and the customer
was pretty uh pissed off uh and uh
we screwed the pooch
um we could have come up with excuses
and there were some legitimate excuses
supply chain was messed up what we did
is we picked up the phone and we said we
messed up
and we don't have any excuse we can give
you excuses but we promised you the
product seven days ago and seven days
later you don't have a product
so we messed up Point number one but
what we are going to do is we're going
to get you ahead of the line
we're going to get you in the next 14
days and this order is on us we took a
big loss but it's okay because we
screwed up
and as I told my company we need to pay
for it it's not like oh we screwed up
sorry sorry is cheap and free but it
doesn't mean anything
we never thought about it Anthony six
months later we got a call from a
different customer said hey we're
looking to bring you guys in by the way
so and so recommended you and genuinely
we didn't know who that was
and then we realized people realize
everybody screws up it's how well you
react to it a lot of people say well
it's not my fault when you say no look
we messed up and we really mean to
You're Gonna fix it and when we fix it
we're going to fix it right
you keep your customer and they keep
coming back to you
there's another part in the book
um about Tesla I did not expect to see
Tesla in this book uh but I want to read
you uh uh a little excerpt this is a
little bit long but uh just bear with me
it says the dynamism of hubs like the
Golden Strip has been brought even to
the long beleaguered U.S automotive
industry thanks in part to Elon Musk he
has made the business sexy Again by
Reinventing the automobile among
America's most mature and iconic
consumer products Tesla's doing what no
one else in the world thought possible
in the process by producing Innovative
electric cars not in a far away low-cost
country but in a technologically
sophisticated Factory in high cost
California the brand is redefining what
it means to be an industrial company
now that is very true I think from my
perspective of
we look at it it kind of feels like a
tech company
but they're making cars
are there other examples that people may
not be as uh familiar with where maybe
it's not a consumer-facing product like
a Tesla car but you're like look this is
a perfect example that lives at the
intersection of the industrial industry
and this technology industry and this is
a good way to see how this is going to
kind of evolve moving forward
it's interesting you asked this because
when we were writing the book we had a
big debate is Tesla a tech company or an
auto company interesting and I said what
do you see in front of you I mean you're
a consumer what do you see you see a car
it does a lot of cool stuff but it is a
car you can buy a GM you can buy a Ford
or you can buy a Tesla it's a car
if it walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck it's a duck
and the best part is I mean you know
there's a lot of news about Elon Musk in
the news so there's nothing about that
but he said look I'm going to take
something as mundane as Auto
applied technology
and change the game
another question you had to ask yourself
is can you change it in other parts of
Industry
we talk about this a lot in the book but
take electrical infrastructure is a
great example which I talk about it
I don't know about you growing up I
never thought about electrical
infrastructure you turn on the light the
lights came off magic magic right
um and if I come to you and I don't know
about you if I said my dad works for a
utility company he'll be like boring
let's move on to something else
but just fast forward now in the next
decade
how you make energy is going to change
you're gonna
you might or might not make it in a
coal-fired plant but hydroelectric yeah
I know how that is solar wind yeah I
heard about it in the last five ten
years but now people are talking about
making it in hydrogen
so you're moving from electrons to
molecules so before you ship electrons
now you're going to ship molecules that
is change
second is before it used to be made
miles away from a plant you probably
never saw a utility plan and then you
came through these big lines now they're
starting to put it right next to your
house
it can be Solar Sun it can be a hydrogen
plant right in your backyard
use electricity so again before you went
and plugged it in and you turned on your
TV now you're plugging your car in
people are now talking about uh planes
uh I don't know if you know uh people
are now talking about electric taxis so
you're in a tier 2 tier 33 why do you
need to take a puddle Hopper if I can
have an electric taxi come to your house
and pick you up and take you to
Miami airport and from there you take
your normal flight so
which we took for granted electricity
has been around for quite some time
flying has been around for the last 100
years
think about it can that change how you
fly absolutely I mean you will say Nick
I've flown all my life and I get into a
plane but ask yourself the question what
happens if flying changes the same way
driving has changed
and I think it will
how you get electricity instead of
having to
go into your house and plug your socket
if you can get and call your utility
company and say oh my God a storm hit us
and lights went out if you can get
electricity different it changes what we
do
and I think for example
the electrical I'm going to call it
energy not even electric the energy
infrastructure because everything you
and I do needs energy
and the aviation infrastructure because
I think people like to drive but people
like to fly or two other things which
are going to change unfortunately I'm
not Elon Musk I don't know what that
company is going to be but if you ask me
to place a bet I'm gonna say you're
going to see that it's um
it's an interesting way to think about
you have no access once you get access
that's kind of a step function change
then you almost get like efficient
access that's another step function
change and then eventually there may be
like even a third step or something that
kind of leads along
um the last part of the book uh that I
thought it'd be interesting to get your
comment on uh is actually close to the
beginning of the book and you say the
titanium economy is the secret weapon
not only for workers and their families
but also for improving socioeconomic
conditions writ large
I don't think a lot of people when they
think of Industrials think about the
humans who work at the companies or the
potential economic impact outside of
just somebody sells this it goes into a
product that I then use in my home talk
a little bit about that aspect of it
that there are people who work at the
companies and and there's usually these
local communities it sounds like uh who
are built around these businesses that
employ a large percentage of the local
population
what is kind of the the direction of
that is that going to expand more and
we're going to see more of this or are
we going to see consolidation in major
metropolitans or how do you think about
it
Anthony there are three statistics I
want to start with and then I'll answer
your question one is an industrial job
or a manufacturing job on an average pay
sixty three thousand dollars a year in
the US compared to a Services which is
thirty thousand dollars
two in 460 counties in this country so
roughly 20 25 counties in this country
manufacturing slash industrial jobs make
more than twenty percent of all jobs
wow and third
people talk about 85 percent of all job
Creations happening in 25 urban areas
New York San Fran Miami
what people don't talk about is there's
an equal number of jobs being created by
the industrial sector
in tier 2 tier 3 cities which you and I
have never heard of meaning think of it
as a diffused model
why do I say that because with this if
you think about it there are two big
customers or sorry two big suppliers for
this industry suppliers of capital which
we have talked about
and suppliers of talent label
and
for a long time people said I'm a smart
kid I went to Harvard MIT Caltech I'm
going to go to the Bay Area I work for
the Googles or the Facebooks of the
world or I'm going to go to Wall Street
and work for uh investment Banks or come
to crypto and work with you
they don't wake up and say wow I'm going
to go to name a city you and I haven't
heard about
for the first time people are saying hey
this is an industry which is going to
put great jobs uh which is going to
allow me to put foot on the table have a
great family have a great life
and when I look at a lot of these
industrial companies people have joined
as I mentioned before and have they are
I don't want to call them High School
dropouts I finished high school but
instead of going to a four-year College
they go to a two-year college or they go
to a trade school and join the company
and grow up the ranks to become a CEO
CFO great position I just said I can do
that I don't have to be the elusive that
one kid in my town who went to Harvard
and did it and everybody else were like
well you didn't win the lottery ticket
but this everybody wins the lottery
ticket and the lottery ticket pays off
well and if you think about our society
I mean the question is do you want to be
the one guy who wins the lottery ticket
or do you want everybody to win the
lottery ticket and have a great future
and this sector allows you to do it
it really does feel like an American
story right the American dream story of
uh there's something about blue collar
type
economies of companies uh that I think
Americans have Nostalgia for a little
bit but one of the things you're pulling
out here is like this is not a story of
50 years ago this is a story of today in
America and people in the tech sector
and the finance sector may not realize
how important it is but it's still uh
very prevalent today
when you look towards the future are
there one or two trends that you think
are imperative for people to understand
around kind of the titanium economy and
how this is going to evolve where you
say look you know if you're a young
person you're looking to get a job these
are are pieces to pay attention to if
you're an investor looking at the
industry these are Trends to pay
attention to like what are the one or
two things that you're like you know if
you don't really know that much about
this sector this is going to be an
important story over the next decade or
so
I think it comes down to two things one
is the good thing the silver lining the
Dark Cloud coming out of covert the
geopolitical risk is people said even in
a virtual world I need physical Goods
um and so the physical goods are enabled
by the industrial sector so the
awareness is happening
I think what has not happened yet is
people don't realize that this is
happening right around you so you look
at an industrial sector you look at
manufacturing companies they're in every
County you don't have to go like if
you're looking for a banking job you
have to go to New York if you're looking
for a tech job you have to go to the Bay
Area in this one if you're looking for
an industrial job 9 out of 10 times it's
somewhere around the corner so Trend one
is
it's around you just have to look and
the second one is
we all are what I call expectation
theories I mean it's not what I have
today what I'm going to have in the
future and how well we do I do think
where we started off with the book and
I'll end with this which is we are in
the first Enix and the next eight
Innings is going to be determined on
what we do as a country what we do as a
society what we do as a sector
I think what we do as a country it
doesn't matter which side of the
political aisle you are I think there
are a lot of good policies coming on
investing in us uh there's a lot of
money coming back
and as I tell this is not a sector which
needs a handout just level the playing
field just don't block me as a lot of my
fellow CEOs will say I don't need your
help but just don't block me if you
don't block me I'll do great and I think
you're saying that but I do think the
rest we control our own destiny so to
your question the best part is
we have the winning lottery ticket we
write the number whether we want to do
it or not it's up to us and I think we
will uh this is why I'm so bullish about
the sector I'm so bullish about the
companies we are working with but we
control our own destiny
you mentioned regulation the political
sphere
um is there one or two things that they
could do to actually help so get out of
the way is is usually a pretty good
strategy uh but it's their deregulation
something that could be passed like is
there anything that you all have
identified where you're like man if this
happened from that uh point of the
economy this would really be a boom
I really think there's only one big
thing where the broadest Society I'm not
even calling the government can help
which is we are going to be limited with
how much great talent we get into the
sector when I started off people people
I bet on people
um I think getting that message out
which is
if you're a 18 year old kid uh you can
have a great future and we as a society
are going to support you we're going to
celebrate you uh and then have the
Investments for example I was in DC a
couple of days ago I was meeting with
one of the local congressmen uh in where
we have our plans and he said what can I
do to help you and I said very simple
just help us in finding the right number
of people and training them and we'll do
the training but we just need the
message out and I think we get the right
Workforce the sky's the limit
I love talking to you because uh you
pretty much know exactly where uh where
my thought process goes
um
training is interesting uh and I've
thought about it I have a friend who uh
maybe six or seven years ago he's one of
my smarter friends that I've ever met uh
he said to me uh I just bought a company
and I said wow that's impressive
congratulations what kind of company and
here I was thinking it was a software
tool or a widget or maybe consumer
packaged goods and he goes I bought an
electrician business and I said that
sounds insane what do you know about
electricians and he said you know he'd
done some work or whatever and
he said I bought it and I can't remember
if it was the first one was in uh
Southern California or in Canada but but
he had bought one he started buying more
and more and more and finally I just
said to him I said hey I thought you
bought one business because it just was
a good business or something like you
obviously have a strategy what is the
strategy and he said well I think that
electricians are not going to get
automated away and what I noticed is
that less and less young people are
going to trade schools where they would
pick up this skill set and so I
understand supply and demand demand does
not appear to change it may actually be
increasing Supply is not keeping pace
and so therefore prices will go up
margins will go up like all these
benefits to a business
I remember saying damn you really are
one of my smartest friends that I know
uh that's that makes a lot of sense
is that also true that same idea of less
and less people are getting trained to
work in some of these jobs in the rest
of the kind of like the broader
industrial sector or are there efforts
being done to try to get people up to
speed and really prepare them for uh for
working in some of these jobs
yes and yes meaning there's absolutely
shortage I mean if you ask me what keeps
me up it's like do we have enough skill
Talent re I mean
I always told us I start my war with the
best people and I end my war with the
best people
um when I look at Funway we carved out
from McKinsey we had the best people I
know we're gonna win because we have the
best team I look at our portfolio
companies I know we're going to win
because we have the best people but then
I'll say do we have enough best people
and the short answer is there's only a
finite pool and so that keeps me up
every night I mean no ifs no buts
are there efforts to train absolutely
but you and I both know there's a cup I
mean if you put somebody into school it
takes them 12 years to come out of high
school and it takes them 20 years to
come out of college and so you're gonna
have this
catch up for a long time
and what makes it worse is the changing
demographics you go back to the 50s and
the 60s a family had four kids so you
can do the math I mean four people went
to school and but they did it now people
are getting married later they have
fewer kids so you can do the math
quickly the the law of numbers is
against us as a society so to answer
your question
I'm not a guy who chases demographics so
I look at the data the demographics is
against us fewer people
and fewer people are having fewer people
so you can do the math and I think what
we found is by 2080 thank God I'll be
dead by then you're gonna have a lot
less skilled talent in the labor pool
than you have today
so you have two choices
one is either find a model Plan B but to
your point like your smart friend said
it's very unlikely to automate an
electrician job because you know I don't
know about you but when my switch gear
doesn't work I wanna I don't want to
call a robot I want to call a human
being who can come and fix it or choose
you just find a plan B on how do you
make them more efficient and get the the
pool
and there's a lot of people thank God in
this country where you can figure a way
out to re-pivot them towards what
matters
think of your career business for 30
years or so
and you look back we want people to
remember
say
it goes back to what my friend said I'm
totally okay being the guy in the
basement when the party is happening in
the penthouse
because I truly believe what we're doing
matters we are truly creating value we
are enabling a lot of great things to
happen
and I'm totally happy being the guy in
the basement as I said maybe one day I
like to go to the first floor uh but no
need to go to the penthouse being in the
basement and creating value
is phenomenal
I love it uh for those who have not yet
read it uh the titanium economy how
industrial technology can create a
better faster stronger America uh it's a
fantastic book I was very impressed I
sometimes people send me stuff and I'm
like huh I wonder if this is going to be
good and uh you know I'll kind of do a
sniff test read the first chapter I was
like oh [ __ ] I might read this in one
day this is fantastic uh so highly
suggest for those uh who are interested
you should go check out this book
um you can get on Amazon stuff like that
where can we send people to find you if
they want to learn more about what you
all are doing either on the investment
side or you personally uh you can find
us on the web funway.com or you can
email me nick.santhem at funway.com
awesome listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this uh it's a
very interesting thesis
um and what I love about it is that this
isn't like some pontification this is
not coming from Academia like somebody
should go do this you all have real skin
in the game uh and you're spending your
time your money your energy uh and
really your reputations to to go and
execute on this and you have a track
record of uh doing it successfully uh so
I I'm just very impressed and I've
really enjoyed our conversation
hopefully we'll do it again in the
future thank you thank you for having me
and uh really appreciate it